Health officials are warning us about an
early and long flu season they say now
is the time to get a vaccine but a new
survey finds only about half of U.S
adults plan to get a flu shot infectious
disease experts are worried about that
CBS News contributor Dr Celine gander is
an epidemiologist and editor at large at
kff's Kaiser health news good morning
how you doing good good so what is most
concerning about flu season
well we have seen the flu really
suppressed over the course of covet so
people have been masking socially
distancing so we haven't really seen
much flu transmission over the last
couple years what that means is there's
a lot less immunity in the population
and so this could be a really bad flu
season so what are the risks
well you know in the winter you might
think of the guy who has the heart
attack as being the guy who's shoveling
his snow in the driveway but what people
don't appreciate is a lot of those heart
attacks are actually caused by people
getting the flu a lot of people yeah
because it's a stress on your lungs on
your heart you have a lot of people who
end up in the hospital because they have
COPD or emphysema who then get the flu
and end up in the hospital so these are
the kinds of things that we really worry
about this season okay so um I want to
ask a question that people may be
wondering at home they say okay I'll get
the flu shot that means I'm not getting
the flu right
the flu shots are a lot like coveted
shots they're very good at keeping you
out of the hospital preventing you from
dying they're so so at preventing you
from getting the flu but the key here is
the win here is keeping you out of the
hospital keeping you alive when is the
best time to get a flu shot now now so
you know I have flu patients in the
hospital right now so we are seeing flu
Transmission in the community it's just
getting started so don't wait get your
flu shot now get ready and go get it huh
get ready thank you so much Dr Gander we
appreciate you